[Music]
welcome back so we're talking about the
Fourier series and how you can
approximate periodic functions using an
infinite sum of cosines and sign waves
and in the last lecture I showed you
that you could approximate sharp hat
functions this kind of triangular hat
function using cosine and sine series
quite accurately and now what I'm going
to show you is what can go wrong okay so
this is going to be a Python code to
walk you through something called Gibbs
phenomenon when you compute the Fourier
series of a discontinuous function so
here I'm defining this top hat function
from zero to ten the size of the domain
doesn't really matter but what matters
here is as opposed to our previous
example which was continuous write this
value continuously varied across this
triangular hat function in our new top
hat function the function is
discontinuous at these two points it
discontinuously jumps from zero to one
and then it jumps back down from one to
zero discontinuously at those two points
and this is gonna be a real problem for
the Fourier series okay so if I included
all infinitely many terms in my Fourier
series I could perfectly approximate
that function even with a countable
number of discontinuities I could still
approximate it but the minute that we
truncate our series now now we're going
to add up the first hundred modes of
sines and cosines we're gonna get a
really interesting numerical artifact of
this approximation or actually it's not
even a numerical artifact it's a real
artifact of this this approximation okay
so I'm gonna walk you through this code
this is very similar to the previous
code what we're doing is we're defining
a domain in the middle half of that
domain we set the value equal to one
everywhere else at zero and then we
compute the first 100 Fourier
coefficients the first 101 coefficients
a K and B K that are multiplying these
cosines and sines and we do this by
taking the inner product of our function
defined on this interval with those
cosines and sines also defined on that
same interval and because this is being
done in a computer
these are not analytic functions what
we're doing is we're defining our
function on a vector of X positions so f
is a vector of data and my cosine and
sine waves are also vectors of data and
we're computing their inner product this
this inner product here just by taking
the dot product of those vectors the F
vector and my cosine and sine vectors
okay and that's how we're getting these
a K and B K coefficients down here and
then we're going to add up those first
hundred and one sines and cosines in
that proper mixture and I'm gonna plot
you the original function and the
Fourier series approximation okay and
when we do that this is what we find we
find so in the background underneath you
can see there's kind of the true hat
function that I want to approximate but
then this blue curve is the Fourier
series approximation with the first 100
sines and cosines and although it gets
the rough trend of a top-hat function
you see this really interesting ringing
phenomenon at the corners at these
discontinuous points okay and this is
known as Gibbs is phenomena and Gibbs
phenomenon Gibbs phenomenon where at
these points of discontinuity actually
does a really good job in the middle
where the function is continuous but at
these points of discontinuity you get
this interesting ringing behavior and
this is something you really have to
look out for when you're numerically
approximating fourier series so again
i'm gonna remind you if i added up all
infinitely many sines and cosines of all
frequencies this would go away i would
have a perfect approximation of my
discontinuous top hat function but the
moment we truncate our fourier series
and we chop it off at let's say 100
modes now we're gonna get this
interesting ringing Gibbs phenomenon
okay and this is this is just pure error
this is an error in approximating the
true top hat function and the reason I
think the way I want to explain this to
you is this is following so the Fourier
series can approximate these these
continuous functions when you have a
discontinuous function sines and cosines
are are continuous right so sines in
code
signs are kind of smooth continuous
functions they don't have sharp corners
or jumps and things like that and so to
approximate something that has a
discontinuous jump essentially what what
this means is that this discontinuous
jump contains all frequencies all
infinitely many higher and higher and
higher frequency signs and co-signs need
to be added up in a perfect mixture to
approximate this the steep front here
this cliff where where the function
jumps from zero to one and if I truncate
my and that when they add up to form
that cliff the ups and the downs of the
different frequency signs and co-signs
are kind of cancelling out perfectly to
just walk up instantaneously and then
stay flat and when I truncate that for
you series in this case at 100 modes I'm
not getting that perfect cancellation of
sines and cosines that I would that I
would have and so now you see the
artifacts because of that imperfect
cancellation I need all of the terms in
my series to get rid of these Gibbs
phenomenon and this is something you're
always going to see when you approximate
discontinuous functions using a finite
truncated Fourier series so for example
if I do this numerically you know in in
Python then I'm gonna get this Gibbs
phenomenon unless I use exactly the same
number of modes as they as I have points
in my in my vector okay
and that's actually the only catch here
is that if I had let's say N equals 1024
points in my discrete representation of
this data then if I had 512 or n over 2
modes this Gibbs phenomenon would look
like it went away
I would I would have a Fourier series
approximation on this grid that is you
know is a perfect representation of my
function but what would happen if you
zoomed in between your grid you would
see this for this Gibbs phenomenon and
essentially what you would find is that
you were just sampling this only at the
points where it intersected exactly with
this function ok so we're gonna get more
into this later I'll tell you more about
Gibson
and especially how this relates to the
fast Fourier transform and the discrete
Fourier transform which is how you
actually compute this on data
efficiently but I just wanted to point
out that this is a big kind of issue
okay and even though we showed that you
can compute the Fourier series of this
triangular hat function if I use the
Fourier series to approximate the
derivative of this which is a top hat
function then the derivative is gonna
have this Gibbs phenomenon so so that's
something that you're you're always
gonna have to look out for is this kind
of ringing Gibbs phenomenon but now
you'll you'll know what it is when you
see it okay and then the last thing I
want to show you here is you can turn
this into a movie where you iteratively
increase the order of this approximation
from K equals 1 to 2 to 3 all the way up
to 100 and you can see how the Gibbs
phenomenon evolves so this is kind of a
cool movie here see if I can play it ok
so it's going to start over in a minute
ok so this is the Gibbs phenomenon as
you increase the order of your
approximation from from low order from a
very coarse approximation to a very high
approximation you can see in the low
order it starts off just being kind of
one cosine function that's a poor
approximation and as you add and add and
add more cosines you see that this Gibbs
phenomena starts to localize out at the
corners so it's doing a better and
better job in the middle and that gives
phenomena that ringing is localizing out
to those points of discontinuity and if
you increased this n higher again to the
number of grid points divided by two
eventually it would look like it goes
away and it's a perfect approximation
but if you doubled your resolution and
zoomed in you'd see that they're still
ringing
you're just a liasing that raining ok
great so something to look out for and
soon we're gonna start talking about the
fast Fourier transform and the discrete
Fourier transform again those are how to
efficiently compute these in a computer
and and we'll we'll use these to
approximate partial differential
equations and remember when you're
approximating derivatives you have to
look out for for Gibbs phenomenon ok
thank you